hi i'm angie hi i'm sarah we're the
winners of the jubilee sweepstakes hope
you enjoy this video
the the specific thing of doing it to a
child that has no say is is something i
kind of the same way as becoming a jew
we have no say yeah but becoming a jew
doesn't necessarily mean doing something
to uh
your private parts
[Music]
step forward if you agree
jewish men
should be circumcised
this is part of my relationship with god
but i don't understand why the rest of
the world would do it i do it because
god says this is my relationship with
you do this and i will be your god
forever when god says to me circumcise
your son in eight days i do it because
that is what jews do
i remember hearing a story of a woman
who was on a transport to auschwitz she
had just given birth to a baby boy and
while she was marching she asked someone
for a knife and the german soldier
mocked her and said you want to make
your you know you want to bring an end
to your life easy sooner
and apparently she took the knife
circumcised her son with the comments so
that he should die a jew
these types of images create such
burning metaphors
that
our families our grandparents will
sacrifice their lives under horrible
conditions
to be able to maintain that that
commandment of circumcision for 3 800
years we jews have done this it's only
been in the last maybe
20 years that people are starting to say
well do we have to do it
the moment you stop
physically doing the covenants and the
religious things assimilation comes in
can they disagree or step forward
i just didn't feel it was appropriate
for me to talk about this because this
is specifically a man issue i'm
circumcised and it's never been you know
a issue for me like i'm never like oh i
wish i wasn't circumcised you know it's
whatever i don't remember it so i have i
guess some qualms with it about doing
that to a baby when they have no say
obviously if you're an adult and you
want to do it
more power to you go for it but the
specific thing of doing it to a child
that has no say is is something i kind
of the same way as becoming a jew
we have no say yeah but becoming a jew
doesn't necessarily mean doing something
to uh
your private parts this is what god
wants this is the first thing that our
father abraham was told by god to do
when god first asked us to do it yes
abraham who then could say yes all right
i will do that he would have done it at
eight days also but god didn't bring it
up until he was 99.
anyway
hi my name is rabbi mintz i am on the
orthodox side i don't believe there's a
god i don't believe in judaism belief
means
that i accept it
because you say so i know there's a god
i know my judaism is real this is the
way god created me this is my purpose
i'm ooze in judaism whether you
recognize it or not
this is who i am
i don't uh uh really believe in a lot of
the religious aspects of being jewish
but i do
love to celebrate celebrate the holidays
with my family it's sort of more of a
state of being to me than
something i
actually do
women and men have separate roles in
society
not necessarily
that we're not equal in a certain way
but especially when it comes to judaism
a woman historically has always been on
a higher spiritual level than men we are
the ones that instill the values the
holiness the culture we are very
strongly a part of the community and
it's important that i'm saying this
because these little tv shows that come
out they like to paint the whole
situation as if orthodox jewish women
are second-class citizens and they just
want to leave the community and it's so
hard for them to exist and they have no
saying and no life and it's not true i
don't
go around saying well we're totally
equal in all areas i have different
responsibilities when i pray
because like you said my soul
needs greater
rectification to reach holiness whereas
my wife's soul it's a local call for me
it's a long-distance call
but we have different roles
i want to feel equal in all aspects of
judaism and all you have to do is go to
the hotel in jerusalem
and take a step back and look at where
the majita is where the divider is
between men and women at the wall and
the men have three quarters of the wall
the women have a quarter and you know
we're all packed in there and i wanted
to have my time to
touch the hotel and pray and i'm trying
to you know have that moment and it was
really hard to not have that moment when
i was there god did create a male female
for a purpose if he wanted us all to be
the same way of practice then we would
have been exactly the same god created
six other genders as well which are also
we'll get to that we'll get to that in a
moment god says i don't trust men
because women are holier i've heard that
that narrative a lot of how women are
holier i think the biggest thing for me
is if a woman wants to
wear a kippah or telus to she feels like
it makes her closer to god why should
she not be allowed to do that i think
that's my biggest add that to your
kosher add that to the mikveh in every
religious home the woman is seriously on
a pedestal in theory that sounds
that sounds good but i think in practice
men are you know praying a certain way
uh to feel closer to god and when women
want to do that they are told they can't
i just want to step in for a second i
want to say even though i do believe
what i believe i still believe that if
people want to do something they have
the right to do so and i'm not going to
judge them for it
i would only marry a jewish person
i
married somebody jewish and i wouldn't
have thought of going out with anyone
else because marriage is not about love
i'm here to build the next generation of
jewish people i'm on a mission as a jew
to keep judaism alive marrying a a jew
is a paramount importance to me
primarily because i see what happens to
many intermarried couples down the down
the road
where i see the fights that creep up
come christmas conica time statistically
the marriage the divorce rate is so high
in this country so why go into a
relationship where you have statistical
obstacles to prevent you from ultimately
having a healthy marriage because i grew
up in a reformed synagogue were very
accepting of different interfaith
families and things like that i mean
definitely is possible but again in all
different walks of life different sects
of judaism it's so different so these
the couples that you are aware of that
were successful in their into marriage
what happened to their children
and specifically were the mothers jewish
or not if the mothers were not jewish
under jewish law the kids are not jewish
the couples i know are still together
some of them the mothers jewish some of
them the father's jewish there are more
progressive values coming up that say
that you know if your father's jewish
will still accept you into the community
because we want as many jews into the
community as possible obviously not
always successful but i have seen those
successful circumstances for sure
i'm ali
i'm here as a secular jew when i
identify as a reformed jew i have dated
a non-jewish person
once or twice and it's something that my
parents didn't love and i actually kept
one parts of it a secret for a little
bit this is the one area where it's
really important for them to for me to
end up with a jewish partner because
again
raising jewish families and celebrating
holidays together it just minimizes
conflict i just find a lot of connection
with other jewish people
just being jewish isn't enough for me to
to being oh well that's someone i i i
want to spend my life with my dad uh
who's who's jewish
when they when he started dating my mom
and when he married her they were uh my
mom was raised christian and she wasn't
jewish she did convert later they
married they it was it was an interfaith
couple for like a couple years every
person who i've dated or who's ever
loved me has not been jewish and i'm
mainly attracted to people who aren't
jewish because i grew up jewish
i am joanna like moana my pronoun is 20
and
i am
a secular jew my family was orthodox i
feel
judged by orthodox jews a lot because
i'm queer presenting i found it very
restricting now being the kind of jew
that i get to be it's a lot more freeing
i get to be me
[Music]
i support israel in its conflict with
palestine
israel deserves to exist israel as our
ancestral homeland also jewish
liberation doesn't have to come at the
cost
of
palestinians losing their their freedom
so in that sense i don't agree with the
last part of it however the conflict is
a different situation
like you were saying it shouldn't have
to come at the expense of palestinians
there is a conflict going on right there
right now what's true for us is
different than what's true for other
people
and we should just be able to live in
peace i know we want that i think
blind support for anything is
problematic i'm canadian do i support
every action the canadian government
takes no do i support canada of course
okay i'm going to say something that's
most probably going to explode this
entire conversation 1947 there was no
such thing as palestinian people they
were jordanians or egyptian citizens in
these jordanian and egyptian citizens
were told by their people go into
refugee camps we'll wipe out the jewish
people and you'll move back in 1964 yasa
arafat came out and said i am going to
raise up a people and call them the
palestinians because we are going to
liberate palestine from the jews the
question was do i support
the conflict between israel and
palestine
i really don't
because the palestine never existed my
issue with it is that you just don't see
them as a people but no no no i didn't
say that
why didn't the jordanians take them in
why didn't the egyptians take in their
citizens i don't know why that happened
but regardless the palestinian
peoplehood was created and we can't take
that away but terrorist but terrorism
comes from it terrorism can come from
anywhere we have it in our own country
i'd like to comment you know i'm a
little sick and tired of the rhetoric
where american jews have to apologize
with this proviso by saying
that israel has a right to defend itself
israel has a right to exist you don't
hear that language
anywhere no no proud citizen of any
country
says america has the right to exist
england has the right to exist do i have
to justify it do i have to bend over
backwards to gain the recognition and
the acceptance of those who are sitting
there like this judging me i won't
there's always this binary terminology
also that's used is very destructive
there is are you pro-palestinian or
pro-israel why is it one of the other
but this is the terminology that they
use when they are only describing it
they don't say are you pro-china or
pro-korea
i want to support israel i love i love
israel i want to love it i want israel
to be a safe place safe haven for you
know jews and people of all you know
religions and backgrounds i'm not saying
that i am
against israel totally pro-palestinian
i'm just saying that there are things
like you said that that israel does that
i
uh in regards to the palestinian
conflict that i don't agree with at all
i mean what you were saying about uh
there being no palestine before you know
1924 there may not have been a palestine
in the country but there was a
burgeoning and growing palestinian
movement and a palestinian identity
since 64. that's not entirely true look
at this
i have looked at the history there was i
mean there's a little disagreement when
exactly it started but there has been a
movement among the people there are
people in that area to to create
because the king of jordan did not want
them anymore in his neighborhood and the
people of egypt said we don't want these
people i think it matters
i don't think it matters why it happened
it just matters that it happened israel
is not causing them to suffer that's
that's not entirely true you show me one
one policy of israel that makes israel
uh that makes the people of these areas
suffer the settlements when they when
they appropriate land from the west bank
the gaza strip and then they they make
the settlements and they make roads and
bridges and transportation that israeli
citizens can use but the palestinians
cannot use fantastic arguments
you're right
so what was the problem before the
settlements
the problem before what was the problem
why was there why was it rising why was
it terrorism before the settlements
there
why was there a massacre in chevron
before the state of israel was created
1927.
i wanted to share with you that when
israel is being attacked let's assume at
the u.n and everyone's coming after
israel
and israel feels very isolated i just
want you to imagine what israelis feel
like when they hear american jews being
critical of them at that moment when
they're feeling so down
they want their brothers and sisters in
america to support them and when you
don't you have to understand that
there's a psychological toll that they
feel and i share that feeling when i see
my fellow american jews not supporting
our brothers and sisters in israel you
defend your family if my brother or
sister did committed a crime was on
death row i would support them
emotionally but i would hope i would
still have the bravery to say what you
did was wrong
i have ancestors who died in the
holocaust
on my grandmother's side my
grandmother's mother
i'm pretty sure had about seven or eight
siblings that
could have been my future like great
aunts and uncles who i never got to meet
well growing up in new york
i didn't know anyone who had a full set
of grandparents
pretty much everyone was a second
generation holocaust survivor i know
that my mother was from uh chernowitz
romania she was transported to a
concentration camp called transnistria
where the germans and the local ruffians
took great pleasure in uh beating up and
killing jews just as recently over this
past job as i learned my great
grandmother
and my grandfather's sister perished at
bobby r
where the nazis would line somebody up
on a ravine and shoot and they would
fall into it into a trap so the
holocaust has uh
very much scarred my psyche in fact many
times i would even fantasize and think
that maybe i'm a survivor maybe i'm a
reincarnation of someone that died in a
concentration camp in a in a gas chamber
because i have such vivid
images etched into my mind because it it
burns deeply within me
what i noticed about
the world we call them holocaust
survivors the children of holocaust
survivors i in my synagogue use a
different word i call them the
rebuilders
because the way the jewish nation was in
europe we were not wealthy we weren't
you know we were living in huts we had
small schools we don't take this kind of
things lightly
we rebuild so i look at that generation
just about all the holocaust people that
came out they said how would we i would
go we going to rebuild
you brought up how your mom was in the
holocaust when she came out was the
first thing that she wanted to carry on
have babies
have a jewish family make up for the
loss
that hitler destroyed her children were
my mother's revenge believe it or not
her vindication
i believe that i carry the blood of my
ancestors in me
that i have a added obligation to bring
honor to their memories who have been
perished and to maintain the faith that
they so staunchly uh
defended so it's not just some footnote
in the past but i believe i i'm an
ambassador of their values
jewish people
benefit from white privilege
america has been playing games where
they decided the irish are now white the
italians are now white but 200 years ago
they were not um i was like eight or
nine or something and i wasn't sure and
i'll never forget like there were these
girls that would always play with this
ball one day i walked up to them and i
was like hey
can i please like uh like whatever i
want to play with you and they were like
oh no your hands are dirty i was like no
look my hands are clean my hands are
clean you know and i checked them i see
and then the girls laughed
at me and they were like hahaha the
dirt's all over you
and they said you're black and dirty and
they left and then they went they ran
away and i was just standing there like
what does that mean every day i walk i
went to sleep i woke up on my place i
shall make me lighter make me lay them
like my sister so that they'll like me
better i just had this ingrown hatred
for my own blackness because of what
someone else said and it also led to
moments of me not even wanting to be
religious anymore
well i disagree with the premise that
there is a white privilege to begin with
i don't think in my grandparents
generation in america when they were
denied jobs because they couldn't work
on shabbos
so they didn't have any white privilege
when jews were not allowed into various
law firms i don't see any white
privilege there growing up in queens new
york having my face kicked in
by the local ruffians i think it is a
myth i am not saying that there isn't
racism
unfair treatment to minorities in this
country i'm well aware of it and i
litigate it all the time if i took off
my jewish jewelry
no one would bat an eye i
live my life as a proud jew because i
want people to recognize my jewishness
and i don't want anyone to find out
after the fact and have maybe regretted
hiring me or you know things like that
but again it's recognizing the fact that
i
pass as a white person in my life it's
hard to recognize what you don't
experience i think part of it is it's
sort of like white privilege doesn't
mean you don't have hardships or have
struggles or or can have terrible things
happen to you it just means that in
america currently
struggles that are hardships that you go
through
white people don't go through them
because they're white they go to them
for a myriad other reasons
i grew up in crown heights where
i was a minority
my parents were very poor
i was given a trip by my uncle to come
down to florida in the 60s it was the
first time i ever saw
we do not serve blacks dogs and jews and
i was on the bottom of the
of the level
i want this country to be what martin
luther king said you shall be judged not
by the color of your skin but by your
actions
if we in america have a problem keeping
to that message and constantly saying
what martin luther king said then we're
off topic there's a thing in america
called redlining it has maintained the
division between
different ethnic groups in america
ever since the civil rights act was
passed and what that means is that if
you live in a certain zip code
and you are from a certain race or
ethnic group you cannot get a loan you
cannot get a mortgage you cannot move
out of there and why aren't there laws
to prevent this why aren't the why is
redlining are the laws that were created
to make this happen so
let's
make america a better place you're from
crown heights you should know red lining
exists there
excuse me you should never there is no
red line
exists there and let me let me explain
this to you redlining
maintains and creates anti-semitism and
anti-blackness how that works i i grew
up doing it how that i put it back
please just let her finish please let
her finish
she's using my hood that's why i'm yeah
so the crown heights that i grew up in
was rough and tumbled yes but when there
was the rioting i got to tell you
something there was a black man sitting
in front of my porch i don't know why
but he was my neighbor and he didn't
want me to get hurt and i got to tell
you something we embraced we loved we
had dinner together the crown heights i
grew up in was
humanity
what does it mean to be a jewish person
in usa being a jewish person in america
today means consistently dealing with
anti-semitism
and never seeing any repercussions for
it which is why i believe that it is
more important ever to be proud of being
a jew in spite of the spikes in
anti-semitism
has increased in the u.s in recent years
uh i agree especially uh where i'm from
in brooklyn i kind of grew up seeing
anti-semitism especially even though i
was a child i like the first
my first experience with it was of
course the riots and if you were
orthodox you felt it because you were
identified you're like an identifiable
jew but if you weren't you didn't know
what was going on and now it's so out of
control
that even people who don't look orthodox
experience a daily
so yeah yeah i mean i run a jewish
instagram page when you look up jewish
on instagram mine is one of the first
things that comes up so of course we
invite the trolls and the anti-semites
and there was this one instance where
these two 13 year old boys were
commenting all over my post saying
i wish your grandparents died in the
ovens i agreed with hitler you know
these are two 13 year old boys where did
they learn this because of social media
people can hide behind the screen people
can hide and they don't have to
in your face i used for years i had a
radio show on kfi radio here in l.a
and then from time to time somebody
would call in and say
i'm not an anti-semite butt yeah yeah
the moment they said that i'm not an
anti-semite it says let me re-correct
you you're an anti-jew
if we took the word anti-semite out
and say no you're an anti-jew do you
know how hard it is for them to defend
themselves and they said it's a cool
word it's not so bad i'm just an
anti-semite i know i never thought about
it like that
what you're saying like this is also
something very new that we're doing
that started on on social media as well
in the past year what some people who
are definitely anti-jewish would say is
how can i be anti-semitic i'm a semitone
so we started using
that yeah
so what we started yeah so the
terminology that we have been deciding
to use now moving forward is anti-jew
hatred
we are god's chosen people
people always talk about jerusalem being
like the holy city and i always tell
people
um you know i was born in jerusalem so
that makes me a holy
we're chosen but our purpose in this
world because some people misinterpret
it as
privilege or that we think we're better
than people no
our purpose in this world is to be a
light to the world let's get to the crux
of what chosen really means when god
created adam and eve god gave them a
religion the religion was seven
commandments to live by when the world
was destroyed because the world wasn't
living by these seven god came to
abraham says i'm choosing you and your
children to do 613
commandments so what does it mean really
to be chosen i got a bigger job for you
christians believe that only christians
go to heaven and everyone else goes to
hell jews don't believe that so when we
say we're the chosen people we're not
saying that we're the only ones that are
good enough to go to heaven like you're
saying we just have more you know a
bigger job to do when i see a general in
an army with all of his medals on his
lapel
and i keep thinking about how proud he
is to be a member of his army
and he wears his
medals with pride i keep thinking
as a jew
i wear my medals with pride and what
comes to mind in response to the prompt
is the prayer that we say on the
holidays
i'll say it in hebrew and then i'll
translate it in english
you chose us above all nations
you love us
and you desire us
and you raised us up above all other
nations there's a love affair between
god and the jewish people i think it's
very very important that we maintain our
pride we wear our medals with pride we
don't apologize for who we are
and we do the best that we can
i'm going to say it was a pleasure
exposing the jewish community
to the world
how beautiful it is when everyone can
sit together and talk hashem
[Music]
thank you for watching this video please
subscribe to this channel for more
videos